who is the best president in your
opinion but beside you let's take your
husband out of it when you go through
history who is vice president that ever
served Lincoln I think Washington why do
you think Lincoln well it would be close
I mean it would be like one degree
difference between Washington Lincoln
first of all they understood the job
right
and they both exercised thoughtful
disciplined approaches to the job George
Washington said don't make me your king
they want that Mexican I wanted to make
him King and then he quit after two
terms right and then he gave a great
speech which people should be reading
every week about avoiding factions
meaning partisanship and you know
putting country over party and all of
that fella that's gone out the window
but I think I mean Washington it turned
out Washington was actually a really
good general and and won the
Revolutionary War deserves a lot of
credit for that but I think Lincoln I
place him and it's very slightly ahead
of Washington because I think Lincoln
faced the worst possible choices you
know Washington was in the creative mode
like we're gonna build this country I've
got smart people around me that's what
the reason I've seen Hamilton four times
I mean I just loved everything about
that and Lincoln you know he had this
view that he had to save the Union and
how do you save the Union when it's a
free and a half slave and and what are
the compromises you're willing to make
and then finally concluded it you know
we can't we can't stay the United States
with slavery you can't it cannot work